hallo mein name ist luca um meine lieben
freunde ich bin ultra high auf das
heutige video denn wir spielen ein spiel
das so ca jeden preis gewonnen hat den
man gewinnen kann und in jedem test zu
diesem spiel steht ebenfalls geschrieben
dass man selbst gar nicht das spiel
spielt sondern das spiel spielt mit dem
spieler an
da habe ich auch ein bisschen angst
okay wir können uns mit gucken
können
[Musik]
das ist ein bild okay
ok ich kann auch schon laufen
wir sind im beruf 427
wir haben gerade 10 5 ich kann nicht
lesen dass hier wird wahrscheinlich
unser büro sein ich glaube wir laufen
einfach mal raus seht ihr auch dazu ein
weil die tür offen steht hier ist 429
büro jetzt 428 da kommen wir nicht rein
[Musik]
die kunden feinde traceur whisky work is
ok
also hier sind anscheinend mitarbeiter
427 und diese person mit dieser
komischen stimme der hier so laut amrum
schreien ist er hat uns gesagt dass alle
mitarbeiter irgendwie verschwunden sind
und wir die einzige person
wenn ich glaube schon
[Musik]
da hab ich nicht bloß nicht alles gleich
aus
ist schuldig
kann es sich einfach so bleiben ist es
wenigstens mal hell aber das ist
generell ganz cool an diesem spiel
bisher das ist halt nicht dunkel ist ich
weiß nicht was noch kommt aber ich hoffe
einfach mal nicht also die person hat
gesagt wir gehen durch die tür links
ich gehe aber rechts durch
ich hab sie wurde das stopp bei den play
downs first just married okay also wir
sind anscheinend durch die falsche tür
gegangen ich dachte ich sie sorgt ein
bisschen dafür das ziel ist den
spannungen beinhaltet und ich mache
nicht das was er sagt kann ich schneller
laufen geht nicht ich kann ich springen
auch nicht kann ich hier drücken geht
auch nicht ich bin im meeting
[Musik]
also es sollte ein bisschen so sein dass
die stimme die hier mit uns redet
irgendwie übergeordnete stimme ist die
uns selbst wir sind nämlich stanley sei
okay er macht
die stimme sagt uns also was wir zu tun
und zu lassen haben von daher hören mit
der stimme jetzt einfach mal zu weil ich
hab kein bock jetzt irgendwie stress zu
bekommen er wollte mich gerade stanley
nimmt die erste tür auf der wii die
trude menschen section rockstar hat die
ovi store n go back on track
er sagt uns dass wir in die richtung
laufen sollen aber da hinten ist es
dunkel
[Musik]
man kann hat hier mit bestimmten dass
die auch hinter einem alles zu machen
soll jetzt auf gleich
ich geh zeit auch nach oben nur
komm wir testen das mal
[Musik]
vom hier
will ich das jetzt neues minecraft
update allerdings ist
ich lade und denkt nicht dass ich hier
keine rolle spielt
nicht einfach wieder hochfahren
[Musik]
zweiter sind jahre später
so
minecraft heruntergeladen zurück
zu dem spiel
[Musik]
dies auch zu
ok
weist sich am ring lukas ist ein ganz
normales spiel
einfach
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht was ich mich eingelassen
habe aber anscheinend
nicht
[Musik]
er sagte wenn das team wieder zu wert
so
dass ich die kugel aus
[Musik]
euro kapital
manchmal auch nicht
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht
was das für ein spiel ist und warum es
so mit mir spielt
aber vorhin waren jedoch noch zwei türen
links und rechts aus
was soll das
ein letztes mal
ich will auch nicht einfach nächsten
meeting herumgehen ich will einfach dass
da wieder zwei türen sind und dann gehe
ich
soll ja zurückgehen
ich komme doch wunder
verloren haben ob wir was vergessen
haben
[Musik]
die spieler dieses spiel nicht mehr
ich habe da keinen bock mehr drauf ich
habe dreimal den übelsten ganz kleine
tür vor meiner fresse zugegangen ist und
damit spielt dieses spiel dieses spiel
will dass man sich manipulieren lässt
dieses spiel will dass ich die ganze
zeit sage ich gehe zurück ich gebe dir
nicht gelingt rechts euro zwei türen und
plötzlich 8 uhr nicht mit mir
nicht mit mir